[Musique]
ravi d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
car en effet je vais pouvoir vous parler
de ma passion car question croyez cette
technologie permet de fabriquer ce que
vous voulez quand vous voulez comme
c'est déjà une petite révolution
aujourd'hui mais je suis intimement
persuadée qu'elle a le potentiel de
créer un véritable bouleversement dans
la vie s'écoule plus poreuse effectué un
voyage mon père dans l'espace et dans le
temps
nous allons suivre les aventures de
steam un jeune homme du futur à travers
lui nous allons comparer le mode de vie
dans les mains de demain à celui dojang
tout d'abord le prêt-à-porter
aujourd'hui pour l'habiller j'ai dû
aller dans un magasin cette semaine j'ai
regardé les différents étages s'il
cherchait quelque chose qui me plaît et
j'ai vu cette chemise à l'oseille la
distance j'ai vu que les prises en même
temps m je suis allée c et puis on aime
je suis punaises peuvent être serré je
passe le réel jeune âge devant mais
quand même j'ai senti la sphère viège la
preuve de lâcheté
aujourd'hui que le jeu dead depuis ce
matin sur quand même un peu serré biétry
ans m
le pire dans tout ça c'est j'ai croisé
trois ou quatre personnes qui avaient
des chemises à carreaux
donc là je pense être confortable
support et là je pense avoir un peu de
style je ressemble à tout le monde en
fait pourquoi ça parce que le
prêt-à-porter d'aujourd'hui c'est du
générique ont fait des milliers
d'exemplaires de chaque vêtement y en a
que quatre ou cinq tailles pour ce monde
ça marchera heureusement je vous dirais
que dans l'avenir il en absolu cette
solution est là s'appelait le dressing 3
et steam donc ce jeune habitant de
demain directement dans sa chambre plus
besoin des magasins il aura ce dressing
3d juste devant lui qui sera représenté
par une planète où il va choisir je veux
donc cette chemise ce tee shirts
pantalons cette couleur texture pourquoi
avoir écrit cette matière et il va faire
quoi il va cliquer sur prise ferme les
yeux creuse non plus tard quand helm
allié israélien
et oui il est content puisqu'il est
complètement qui sont à son goût
puisqu'il et sera sélectionné
personnalisé juste avant mais surtout il
sera au top de son confort puisque ces
vêtements seront à s'adapter à sa
morphologie
demain il fera plus de génériques dans
le prêt-à-porter nous ferons du sur
mesure pour chaque pour représenter ces
affirmations
voici deux coquines de steam voici sur
la gauche sabrina qui est l'âme esprit
refuse aux excentriques donc ne fait
ressortir dans ces événements c'est
quelque chose d'effectivement qui l
hymne habituel sur des femmes fatales
qui sont faites par un patient travail
sur la droite vous avez cette fois-ci
julie utilise plus réservés elle a
choisi une robe toute en simplicité mais
avec une structure alvéolaire clients
dire au maximum dans tous ses mouvements
demain ce sera la violence du style et
du confort on a parlé des goûts
vestimentaires mais parlons gustatif
parlons des papilles si je pouvais
manger pour ce soir il faudrait que
j'aille faire des courses une échelle
des aliments d accompagnement et d
assaisonnement jeu pour des trucs qui ce
mix bien entre eux et que je fasse on
pourra manger ça c'est dans la théorie
en vrai je suis le pire cuisinier du
monde
et quand je vais dans les magasins je
suis comme un enfant jusqu'au paiement f
ce poêle à bois ou le point limite je
comprends rien c'est pour ça que j'ai ma
chance par contre j'aime petite amie qui
est très doux les trains ce domaine qui
me prépare une petite liste j'ai vu qu'à
suivre les instructions du show comme ça
tu prends comme ça si tu es et le soir
quand je rentre je sais que j'ai un plat
savoureux et équilibrés qui m'attend
quand même formidable ça c'est quand
même assez pratique mais est ce que tout
le monde est dans ce cas enoch pas
forcément team lui dans l'avenir
il est jeune et célibataire autant vous
dire que ils pouvaient manger bien gras
et bien installée mais malheureusement
pour lui même s'il est célibataire il
aura une solution l'autocuiseur 3d eric
plus jeunes à y faire les magasins
directement dans sa cuisine
l'autocuiseur 3d sera connecté à son
corps sera ce qu'il a besoin quand il en
a besoin et comment les deux souhaitent
en même pas besoin de cliquer le sera
élu fera un bon plat équilibré et
surtout beau car oui vu qu'on peut faire
les formes un peu plus chaudes on va
pouvoir se permettre de manger quelque
chose de plus original en apéritif des
petits tubes qui est impressionnant les
amis de steam et sur la bref une salade
du champêtre revisité en structure
fractale
ça ne m'arrive donc demain encore une
fois on a changé de système vraiment
manger du sur mesure et en plus ça va
être vraiment beaucoup plus simple tout
le monde aura accès à une très bonne
alimentation
c'est d'autocuiseurs 3d et tous les
autres accessoires 3d qui l'aura team
demain il va bien falloir des classes et
quelques bars et se dit aujourd'hui mon
logement devient trop petit je voudrais
avoir plus haut et bien moi donc raison
que je fais exactement la même réflexion
pour les mêmes raisons mais je le dis
quand le joueur est trop petit et je
voudrais avoir une maison
tant qu'à faire je voudrais la
construire mon image à ça ça serait bien
mais je meurs tu as deux choses ça va me
coûter beaucoup d'argent et c'est un
point de beaucoup de temps pourquoi
parce que la construction d'une maison
actuellement c'est un véritable bal il
ya des dizaines de personnes qui y
travaillent plusieurs corps de métiers
qui doivent se succéder celui là le
brassard il est dans ce cas
on a des jeunes qui en retard ça des
cadeaux on se retrouve avec des semaines
des mois voire possiblement des années
pour avoir sa maison et tous ceux le
ccor de médecine à ces deux-là vendeur
donc il faut la payer
normal moi cela me coûtait des soudards
donc si je veux avoir une maison en gros
il faut que je passe un très gros chèque
un prêt sur 30 ans et en plus que je ne
sois pas très pressé or le besoin l'aide
actuelle et je n'ai pas d'argent ce
niveau là donc normaux ben moi j'aime
bien ce soir sur la mi mai télévie dans
un monde hyper sympathique
oui il y aura des mérides et notamment
il y aura la grue froide et oui un
nouveau pan de sa tablette
il va voir au ce terrain avec plutôt
sympa et qui fâchent et j'avais parlé
des plans aller quelque part ailleurs
oui mais sur la tablette pris goût et à
partir de larmes fait sur le terrain
qu'il vient d'acheter directement une
grue 3d va venir se mettre en place de
façon complètement autonome commencé à
construire les fondations les murs
portes fenêtres toiture et même le
mobilier tant qu'à faire
et cela en une journée en même pas 24
heures qui ne pourra passer la clé dans
sa maison égalité et par dessus le
marché
ça va écouter les hymnes pilotes et oui
car non excusées toute la main d'oeuvre
moi j'ai besoin de discuter mais est
épars sur le marché le pire dans tout ça
c'est qu'il a fait tellement d'économies
qui pourraient se payer ma maison de
vacances vu deux mains de toute façon
acheter sur terre ce sera franchement à
ce film robin va acheter sa maison
secondaire sur la lune ou sur mars
il a bien acheté d'ailleurs si moi
j'avais envie d'aller sur mars
comment est ce que je vous ferai
question aujourd'hui nous avons des
moyens de transport qui sont physiques
c'est-à-dire que si je voulais y aller
moi conserver son avance fois je ferai
ma voiture jusqu'à l'aéroport
ensuite l'aéroport l'avion jusqu'à la
fusée fusée qui peut même un gros engin
explosion qui nous envoie dans l'espace
pas très sécuritaire ça mais une fois
qu'on est dans l'espace il ya encore six
mois de trajet pour arriver sur mars ce
sera très probablement de l'essence
au passage si on a environ je suis un
geek je m'assume j'aimerais aller dans
l'espace mais pas à ce prix là chien
revient donc pour l'instant que
j'élabore la concernant mais encore une
fois si moi-même passé de réflexion
demain car demain n'aura le transport
dématérialisée et notamment grâce au
téléport travail ça vous paraît fou ça
ou pas de la science fiction mais je
vous dirais que oui et je me dirais que
mon le matin même au boulot je prends ma
facture que l'as cannes je l'envoie par
internet et qu'elle et réimprimé chez
mon client je crois la définition de la
téléportation
je suis simplifier c'est l'action de
déplacer un point physique d'un point a
à un point b à travers internet virtuel
quand je vois une facture par internet
avec mon fils c'est la téléportation
primitive mais sans elle dit ému et dans
l'avenir l'hénoret juste en fait à
prendre le thé par 3d qui n'est ni plus
ni moins qu'une imprimante 3d vient
d'annoncer il va entrer dedans
il va être complètement numérisés
envoyés à travers internet et réaffirmé
dans sa maison de la vence en diable
l'impasse taper les six mois j'ai fait
c'est quand même pas mal qu'un sacré
l'an dernier notamment merveilleux enfin
fonder un des points et je vais aborder
avec vous un un financement dans le vif
avec médical cap ils eurent imaginons ce
matin revenant à mon transport physique
le centre sur l'autoroute un camion semi
remorque vient de plaquer sur la rampe à
tous nous et c'est autant bien j'ai peu
de chance de survie mais heureusement
arrive à l'air à l'hôpital je vois
toujours vivant je reprend conscience
quand même et à choisi contiendra
ensuite je vois quoi le dj branchés
royaume gère le médecin des pauvres
quel futur ascenseur émotionnel dans le
coup il le dit rassurez-vous nous avons
un coeur de rechange pour vous chez
pourra servir
ok ok mais vainqueur mais ce sera celui
d'un étranger fut jurée dans mon corps
et mon bras
on ne l'aura pas pour autant remplacer
la médecine d'aujourd'hui
bien qu'elle avance assez vite les
relativement limité on ne fait pas de
miracle
heureusement vous vous doutez bien
commun lié à une solution d'impression
travail puisque on aura demain la bio
imprimante 3d sait s'il sera capable de
récupérer votre adn d'un cheveux ensuite
de le cultiver pour fabriquer un coeur
ou un organe au complet cet organe on
pourra vous l'implanter facilement
puisqu'il sera fait d'autres propre
métier il n'y aura donc aucun objet
demain on voit ainsi éliminer la pénurie
d'organes et tout le monde aura une
chance de survivre un accident c'est
quand même plutôt formidable besoin un
parallèle avec eva l'univers de tim en
arrivant sa maison de vacances sur mars
sont téléporteur dire un problème de
réseau nas mauvaise couverture heureuse
ça c'est ballot mondiale que lui manque
une jambe a fait un des biens en grande
souffrance
s'il arrive à attraper en fait un
boîtier rougier sur les téléports 3d non
ce n'est pas un défibrillateur très
juste et utile c'est une bio imprimante
3d portative il peu accessibles sur sa
cuisse mutine elle s'adapte à des jeunes
et commence avec en prime quelques
instants une jambe ou teneur rien un
quart d'heure plus tard c'est qu'un
bilan
mais soyons un peu plus agi comme avec
steam et si on se disait qu'il y avait
vraiment un gros homme de réseaux de
voir la machine complètement planté deux
teams
il n'arrive carbou 8 pouces peau à berne
a toujours essayé de rattraper mais
heureusement le téléport travail et vie
il aura une sécurité a appelé les
secours
ceux ci vont arriver tu perds le bout de
pouce dans le film le fils à jo
une fois arrivée à l'hôpital me place de
dieu imprimante 3d mais cette fois ci à
taille humaine et à partir de son pouce
elle va reconstituer tout son corps au
complet et ainsi redonner vie intime
en clair on travaille pourra rendre team
immortel bon après la désignation de le
tasser fatigué je vais rouler ces teams
se reposer en iran le faire vous l'aurez
compris l'impression 3d un potentiel qui
même puisque colossal
on parle de téléportation et
d'immortalité crème paris mais il faut
bien se dire que derrière chaque machine
il ya un nom une femme pourrait être
vous qui est capable du meilleur comme
du pire qui peut faire un tueur commune
à et nous appartient donc à nous
l'espèce humaine de se poser une
question à l'ong faire en sorte que
l'impression 3d devienne le pilier
bienfaisant du monde de demain merci
[Applaudissements]